let's talk about this show congrats on
season two of modern love
i think this is a series that everybody
in the world needs right now
there's never enough love in the world
kit would you consider yourself a
romantic
is that why you wanted to take part in
this i would consider myself a romantic
um i'm not sure it's the reason i wanted
to take part in this
i think i wanted something light-hearted
to do
but not without importance and i think
this piece
is uh based around the pandemic and has
some really interesting questions to say
to ask about it um
yeah romance for me is very important i
think it's no matter what stage you are
at in your relationship marriage yeah
romance is really important i
loved you and lucy together in this my
biggest complaint about this episode
is that there wasn't more i could have
watched an hour and a half of you two
together
were you really strangers on a train
before doing this or had you two met
before because the chemistry was
there it was incredible and like i said
i wanted more
i uh we were i'd never met lucy before i
was
very aware of her work and knew that she
was a bit actress
and um so i knew i was in safe hands
there
um i uh got on with her really well
i completely agree with you i wish i
wish i'd had more
time with her on screen um but i think
if we managed
the the object of this is if we managed
to
create something that people believed uh
that we could be sort of in love then in
one scene then we've done our job
you did your job i was so old like i
said maybe modern love season three we
can pick up this story
i would love to see it for sure um let's
talk
about love we love love at et canada
i have a confession for you i kind of
have a modern love story i met my
partner of 12 years
through craigslist and the day we met i
know
the day we met in person i knew from
that moment
that this was the man for me and here we
are 12 years later
you of course met your lovely wife on
set of game of thrones
did you have that immediate connection
that you kind of just
knew from that moment of meeting that
you were like okay
this is this is my person by the way
craigslist that's unorthodox
i like it i feel like but i feel like
game of thrones was the craigslist of
of tv there we go
um i um yeah i
i still look back with great fondness
at the time me and my wife matt and
um i don't know if i necessarily i think
that i
i all i remember thinking was i'm in
trouble i was there
it was like this one's trouble this one
could
could could be everything and painful
and wonderful and
and the whole thing the whole thing in
between um
and i think that's what love is you go
oh god i'm in trouble here
yeah absolutely there was a lot of heart
to this episode but there is also a lot
of humor and one of the things
that i laughed at for quite some time
was the
uh poking fun at the celebrities doing
the imagine video
at the start of the pandemic i still
put that video on because it always
makes me laugh
what was your reaction when you first
saw that video
i my heart went out to all of them
because i think they were trying to do a
really lovely thing
and there's the risk with social media
nowadays isn't it that yeah
do something try and do a lovely thing
and and it comes across in the wrong way
um yeah but i do think everyone should
be allowed to be taking the piss out of
for something they do
and i think that's one of the things
that i loved about this episode was it
it's kind of modern cultural references
that it
broke in there which really date it in a
quite an interesting way and i think
that that um
that lets them not get away with it
[Applause]
so you're telling me that you will not
sing britney spears work [ __ ] with me
to
inspire millions around the world to
achieve their dreams
i never said that dallas you want to go
for it let's go i'm not going to do that
no we are not we'll do that off camera
sometime
listen everyone is so excited for
eternals which is coming this november
i'm so excited myself um i do have to
ask
after that viral tick tock video of you
seeing the slot machine
are you making sure that merchandising
rights are part of that contract
yeah i'm cool with my agents uh on a
regular basis
yeah you gotta make sure of that finally
you know
love is complicated in 2021 and the idea
of a traditional love story
really um is kind of out the window
rainbows puppy dogs and butterflies
life is much more complicated than that
um with such a busy life
that you have how do you make uh modern
love
work when you're just kind of going
going going are you like a face timer
constantly texting i um
yeah i think that one thing that
pandemic did show
us was that there was there was joy in
being together
in a kind of in a in a in a lockdown
i found really
not going anywhere and not being able to
go anywhere just being with
my wife meant that we went and had a
baby you know it's like it
it's uh that can teach us something
um and as much as this zoom
facetime stuff is gets a bit tiring
imagine we didn't have it you know i
know you didn't have it
my my mother has got a relationship with
her
first grandchild purely through facetime
at the moment that's no
thing well congrats on this serious kit
fantastic talking to you
and um can't wait to see what's next for
you appreciate it
thanks dallas take care
you